"THE FIVE."
FLORIDA ONCE AGAIN THE EPICENTER
OF A MAJOR POSTELECTION BATTLE.
ALLEGATIONS OF FRAUD ARE BEING
THROWN AROUND AS TWO KEY RACES
MOVE CLOSER TO RECOUNT.
BROWARD AND PALM BEACH COUNTY
CAUSING SENATE CANDIDATE RICK
SCOTT TO FILE LAWSUITS ACCUSING
OFFICIALS THEY ARE OF TRYING TO
STEAL THE ELECTION.
>> THERE MAY BE RAMPANT FRAUD
HAPPENING IN PALM BEACH AND
BROWARD COUNTIES.
AND THE BROWARD SUPERVISOR OF
ELECTIONS HAS A HISTORY OF
ACTING IN ABSOLUTE BAD FAITH
WHICH REQUIRES THAT VOTE BY MAIL
AND ABSENTEE BALLOTS ARE COUNTED
WITHIN 30 MINUTES OF POLES
CLOTHING.
I WILL NOT SIT IDLY BY WHILE
UNETHICAL LIBERALS TRY TO STEAL
THIS ELECTION.
SENATOR NELSON HIRED ONE OF
HILLARY CLINTON'S LAWYERS FROM
D.C. IN THE FIRST THING THEY
SAID IS THEY ARE HERE TO WIN THE
ELECTION.
>> IF YOU LOOK AT
BROWARD COUNTY, THEY HAVE HAD A
HORRIBLE HISTORY.
IF YOU LOOK AT THE PERSON, IN
THIS CASE A WOMAN INVOLVED, SHE
HAS HAD A HORRIBLE HISTORY.
ALL.
ALL OF A SUDDEN THEY ARE FINDING
VOTES OUT OF NOWHERE.
RICK SCOTT, WHO WON BY, YOU
KNOW, IT WAS CLOSE, BUT HE WON
BY A COMFORTABLE MARGIN, EVERY
COUPLE OF HOURS AGO WAS DOWN A
LITTLE BIT FOR THE VOTES DON'T
EVER SEEM TO GO THE REPUBLICAN
WAY.
IT'S INTERESTING.
IT ALWAYS SEEMS TO GO THE WAY OF
THE DEMOCRATS.
>> Dana: BRENDA SNIPES TAKING
THE BRUNT OF THE CRITICISM.
SHE COULDN'T GIVE AN ANSWER ON
HOW MANY BALLOTS ARE LEFT TO BE
COUNTED.
>> COULD YOU UPDATE WHERE THINGS
ARE ON THE COUNT RIGHT NOW?
>> Dana:
COULD I PLEASE GET A MOMENT TO
GO INTO THE ROOM AND FIND OUT?
>> Dana: THIS BREAK IN A JUDGE
SIDED WITH RICK'S CAMPAIGN TO
ALLOW VOTER RECORDS 7:00 P.M.
TONIGHT.
YOU JUST SAW SOMETHING ON
TWITTER?
>> >> Greg: YES, DANA, I LOVE O
BREAK NEWS.
I HAVE BREAKING NEWS ON MY
PHONE.
I'M GOING TO START READING THIS
FROM MY PHONE.
HERE WE GO WITH SOME BREAKING
NEWS.
THIS IS A TWEET FROM MARCO
RUBIO.
YOU MIGHT REMEMBER HIM FROM
RUNNING FOR PRESIDENT.
I BELIEVE HE'S A SENATOR?
DATA: OF FLORIDA, YES.
>> Jesse: LITTLE MARCO.
>> Greg: PALM BEACH COUNTY
FILLED OUT NEW BALLOTS TO
REPLACE KNOWLEDGE, DAMAGED ONES
WITHOUT ALLOWING CAMPAIGN REPS A
WITHOUT ALLOWING CAMPAIGN REPS D
WITHOUT ALLOWING CAMPAIGN REPS I
WITHOUT ALLOWING CAMPAIGN REPS T
IS OVERSEEING THE NEW PALLET
HERE YOU HAVE DEMOCRATS WHO HAVE
BEEN SCREAMING AND YELLING ABOUT
RUSSIAN COLLUSION AND
INTERFERING WITH ELECTIONS AND
ALL THE TIME THE CALL HAS BEEN
COMING FROM INSIDE THE HOUSE.
IT'S THE DEMOCRATS WHO ARE
COLLUDING AND INTERFERING WITH
ELECTIONS.
HOW CONVENIENT THEY FIND THESE
VOTES AFTER THEY LOSE!
>> IT TOOK A LONG TIME TO
FINALLY CALL THE ELECTION.
RICK SCOTT, THE GOVERNOR, GAVE A
VICTORY SPEECH BEFORE FOX NEWS
HAD ACTUALLY CALLED THE
ELECTION.
THEN HE DID AND RIGHT AFTER HIS
VICTORY SPEECH WHEN FOX NEWS
CALLED ON THAT MADE THE CALL,
BUT NELSON NEVER CONCEDED AND HE
HIRED MARK ELIAS, HE WAS AL FRAN
HIRED MARK ELIAS, HE WAS AL FRAE
HIRED MARK ELIAS, HE WAS AL FRA'
HIRED MARK ELIAS, HE WAS AL FRAS
LAWYER WHEN NORM COLEMAN LOST IN
2008.
MARIE: EVERY VOTE NEEDS TO BE
COUNTED.
>> Greg: THE TALKING POINTS...
>> IT NEEDS TO BE DONE
TRANSPARENTLY.
A JUDGE HAS RULED THEY NEED TO
BE MORE TRANSPARENT AND
BROWARD COUNTY AND I THINK
THAT'S A GOOD THING.
THIS IS ONLY THE INITIAL COUNT.
WE ARE NOT IN THE QUESTION OF
THE RECOUNT AND THEY ARE CLOSE
ENOUGH, DEFINITELY ONE OF THE
RACES IS CLOSE ENOUGH, THE
GOVERNOR'S RACE COULD END UP
CLOSE ENOUGH AS WELL APPEAR
THERE IS AS OF THIS POINT THERE
IS NO EVIDENCE WE HAVE SEEN A
VOTER FRAUD.
THERE IS A LOT OF ALLEGATIONS.
THERE IS A LOT OF PEOPLE WHO
HAVE PARTISAN INTEREST IN THESE
RACES MAKING CLAIMS.
WE JUST NEED TO TAKE A DEEP
BREATH.
WE NEED TO HAVE SOME
TRANSPARENCY.
WE NEED TO HAVE THE VOTES
COUNTED.
WE ALSO KNOW GOING FORWARD NEED
TO MAKE OUR ELECTION SYSTEMS
BETTER IN TERMS OF HOW WE DO
THIS.
>> Greg: DO YOU LIKE BETTER
IDEA?
THAT WOULD BE GREAT.
>> Jesse: THERE ARE A LOT OF
MAIL INS OVER THERE.
MARIE: THE FACT THAT FLORIDA HAS
NOT FIXED THEIR SYSTEM IS
ACTUALLY PRETTY CRAZY.
>> Dana: JESSE, HOW DO YOU
THINK ABOUT THOSE?
DATA OPHTHALMIC >> Jesse: HE
THINKS HE'S GOT IT, THE BUSH
RECOUNT, HE ONLY
HAD A -- IT'S VERY COMFORTABLE.
A DAY GOES BY AND ALL THESE
VOTES COME IN FROM BROWARD.
THAT'S KIND OF FISHY.
MORE VOTES COMING IN FROM
BROWARD.
THE VOTES COMING IN FROM
BROWARD, 3-1 DEMOCRATS.
THAT'S A 2-1 DEMOCRAT AT BEST
KIND OF COUNTY.
THEY SQUEEZE IT DOWN TO 15,000
VOTE MARGIN TRIGGERING A
RECOUNT.
VERY INTERESTING.
LISTEN.
THIS WOMAN, WE ARE TALKING ABOUT
RIGHT NOW, SNIPES -- WE CALL HER
SNEAKY SNIPES.
>> Dana: DO WE?
>> Marie: DO WE?
>> Dana: THAT'S NOT WHAT WE
CALL HER.
>> Jesse: SHE'S GOT A HISTORY
OF THAT.
SHE IS ALREADY ACCUSED OF BALLOT
STUFFING, HIDING AMENDMENTS FROM
BALLOTS, A JUDGE HAS RULED SHE
ILLEGALLY DESTROYED BALLOTS.
>> Marie: NOT IN THIS CASE.
IS THERE ANY EVIDENCE IN THIS
CASE?
>> Jesse: IN 2018 AND SHE WAS
ACCUSED OF NOT ALLOWING SCOTT'S
REPRESENTATIVES WATCH THEM FILL
A PROVISIONAL BALLOTS AND THE
JUDGE BECKER DOWN AND SAID IT'S
TIME TO OPEN UP THE DOORS
BECAUSE YOU ARE DOING EVERYTHING
IN SECRET.
HER JOB IS TO KNOW HOW MANY WERE
CAST, HOW MANY WERE COUNTED, HOW
MANY LEFT TO BE COUNTED.
SHE SAYS SHE HAS NO IDEA.
THE FACT SHE'S NOT COMMUNICATING
TO THE PUBLIC OR THE CAMPAIGNS,
HOW MANY VOTES CAST COUNTED AND
TO BE COUNTED, IS SUSPICIOUS.
IF YOU DON'T KNOW THE
TABULATION, THEN ANYTHING CAN
HAPPEN UNDERNEATH.
THAT IS WHY THIS WOMAN, NO ONE
HAS FAITH IN HER AT ALL BECAUSE
ESPECIALLY THE WAY SHE'S
CONDUCTED HERSELF THIS DAY AND
TWO YEARS AGO.
>> Marie: THERE'S NO EVIDENCE.
FOR YOU TO DO YOU KNOW THAT
THING ON THE INTERNET, "YOU HAVE
ONE JOB?"
>> Dan: YOU HAD ONE JOB,
SNEAKY SNIPES!
YOU CAN'T EVEN COUNT THE JOKE.
THEY
EVIDENCE OF IRREGULARITIES IS
EVERYWHERE.
THEY HAD THE VOTES POSTED
30 MINUTES AFTER THE POLLS
CLOSED.
THEY DIDN'T.
THAT'S A MATTER OF FACT.
I AGREE WITH YOU COME EVERY VOTE
SHOULD BE COUNTED.
THE QUESTION IS WHEN?
WHAT IS FLORIDA DOING, LATE
VOTING NOW?
WE ARE DOING POSTELECTION
BALLOTS?
>> Jesse: DEMOCRATS ARE
OUTPERFORMING REPUBLICANS IN THE
LATE VOTE.
>> Marie: THEY ARE SLOW TO
COUNT IN FLORIDA, THEY ARE SLOW
TO COUNT AND LOTS OF STATES!
>> Dan: AS GREG ACCURATELY
STATED TO HIM HAS NO IDEA HOW
MANY VOTES ARE TO BE COUNTED.
YOU HAVE ONE JOB!
>> Jesse: SHE DIDN'T
COMMUNICATE TO THE CAMPAIGNS OR
THE PUBLIC WHAT THE VOTE COUNT
IS.
THAT'S REQUIRED BY LAW.
>> Juan: THE JUDGE RULED
AGAINST HER AND YOU ARE RIGHT
THERE BY 7:00 P.M., SHE SHOULD
HAVE THOSE NUMBERS OUT.
I THINK SHE SHOULD BE
TRANSPARENT.
I DO NOT THINK WE SHOULD JUMP TO
THE CONCLUSION THAT BECAUSE THE
RACES TIGHTENING WHEN OFTEN
PROVISIONAL BALLOTS GET COUNTED
THAT THEY ARE SOMEHOW FRAUD.
WE HAVE TO WAIT FOR EVIDENCE.
SOCIAL BRIAN KAMPE OVERSEEING
GEORGIA?
>> Dan: I DO NOT THINK
EVIDENCE MEANS WHAT YOU THINK IT
MEANS.
HOW DO YOU NOT HAVE THE VOTE
COUNT?
>> Marie: POINT OUT VOTER
FRAUD EVIDENCE TO ME.
>> Dan: SHE'S NOT BRINGING
PEOPLE INTO PHILIP THE
PROVISIONAL --
>> Marie: WE DON'T KNOW THAT.
>> Dan: ACCUSATIONS ARE
EVIDENCE!
>> Marie: NO, IT'S NOT!
>> Jesse: WHY WOULD THEY FILE
A LAWSUIT IF WE CAN'T WATCH
WHAT'S MY WIFE FILED A LAWSUIT
IF YOU ARE ALREADY WATCHING?
>> Marie: A LOT OF THE LAW
SUITS WERE GOING TO SEE IS GOING
TO BE ON SHAKY GROUND.
WE SEE IT IN EVERY RECOUNT.
WE NEED TO LET THE EVIDENCE TAKE
US WHERE IT IS.
>> Dan: IT'S JUST AMAZING --
AND THAT'S NOT GOOD.
GREG, WILL GO BACK TO YOU.
>> Dana: HALF OF THE
POPULATION IN FLORIDA THINK THE
OTHER HAVE SAID SOMETHING TO
STEAL THE ELECTION FROM THEM.
THAT'S NOT GOOD.
>> Greg: THE DAMS WANT TO MAKE
AMERICA SUFFER.
IT'S LIKE DEMANDING AN EXTRA
INNING.
I HAVE A NEW NICKNAME FOR BILL
NELSON.
RECOUNT DRACULA.
WE PREDICTED THIS LAST WEEK.
WE SAID NO MATTER WHAT THE
OUTCOME WAS, WHETHER THE DEMS
WIN OR LOSE THEY WILL BE HAPPY.
THIS IS TOO MUCH OF THEIR LIFE.
>> Marie: I'M HAPPY.
>> Greg: YOU ARE DIFFERENT,
MARIE --
B1 CAN I SAY SOMETHING, I LOST
>> Dan: I CONCEDED.
YOU CAN GO ON
"THE DAILY CALLER," I WROTE A
VERY NICE LETTER TO JOHN
DELANEY.
THIS IS TIME TO MOVE ON.
>> Marie: YOU LET THE ABSENTEE
VOTES GET COUNTED.
>> Dan: THAT'S THE RULES!
WHY DIDN'T SHE POST AFTER
30 MINUTES?
>> Marie: SHE WILL TONIGHT.
>> Greg: THE LESSON IS NEVER
CONCEDE.
JESSE MADE A GOOD POINT AND WE
LAUGHED ABOUT IT.
>> Marie: DON'T CONCEDE.
AND BILL NELSON NEVER CONCEDED.